the time has come friends the time has
come it's come for me and my ps4 cohorts
and have a demo to Final Fantasy 7 the
remake is out now you haven't played it
you should if you did why wouldn't you I
don't mean to be redundant but you might
get a little bit of redundant
information in this video because for me
it's now like I kind of kept my head
down for this one like I don't want to
see any trailers I just want to know
that it's happening and I just want to
experience it for the first time when I
play it I was like oh a minute and a
half long trailer I'll watch it haha I
melted I was like a kid again so the
demo for this game is the exact demo for
the original Final Fantasy 7 like the
demo 4 7 is the same thing it's the
Mokka reactor bombing run the beginning
of Final Fantasy 7 I played the demo for
the original back in the day which is
the only reason anyone ever bought or
rented to a ball number 1 who rented it
for like I made the demo does the game
would that do guy blockbuster was like
weirdos he gave us a disc so the format
is very familiar I'm glad that this is a
demo we get I'm glad they came out with
the demo because it's just it throws it
back you know and there's a lot to love
about this right first of all if you
want the turn-based RPG the old-school
element it's not that it's not that it
does have strategic elements in it
though and I appreciate that but if you
want the turn based Final Fantasy 7
formula there's the HD remaster I got
that just got done playing that on my
switch cuz I was like alright chapter 1
of this rimae is gonna go through Midgar
so I just want to play the original
through Midgar and I just didn't stop
playing and then I beat the game first
in this demo I was like okay so it is
like an action game you know your
ex-wife swipe swipe your slashing
enemies so you're building up points for
a meter in which all right now the
meters built up now you can do more
stuff now you can use your magic which
does still use em Pig do you see the
materia the green materia and cloud
sword but I'm hoping the materia system
is a lot like it was in Final Fantasy 7
because mixing some of this material
it's the fun part of the game you've
killed me final tack nights at the round
[ __ ] you or Phoenix that's the smarter
one I suppose there's something about
that spiteful you killed me sometime
hitting you for over 100k kind of thing
I like that so yeah you attack you build
up your meter now you can use magic and
you can switch between cloud and Barret
which are the voice cast it's just
perfect because it wasn't voice acted in
the PlayStation but when reading
Barrett's lines Barret I'm pretty sure
this voice actor he's who I heard it's a
great faithful reproduction of Barrett's
care
and seeing the interaction between cloud
and Barret in this demo made me look
forward to the relationship building
among the characters in this cinematic
quality playable action RPG movie you
know what I'm saying I mean it was great
in the original and the capacity that
Lord of the Rings the books are great
but if you can take what you have there
if you can take the on wonder that your
imagination filled in the gaps for and
then you can give it to the audience in
this grand scope cinematic formula we
had not prepared seriously we're gonna
weep so some enemies are up high and
Barrett's better at that so you just
click over to Barrett now you're using
him the computers controlling cloud it
really the combat kind of reminded me of
and I know a lot of people out there
gonna be like it's actually closer to
this other game you've never played but
this is just my spectrum this is this is
the comparison I have it reminds me of
an action RPG Bioware game like Mass
Effect was swords so I guess the dragon
hitch a little different but when you
push the spell button and everything
slows down you're selecting what spell
to use on which character definitely
reminded me of that or a more complex
version of what Crisis Core had going on
much faster paced in crisis course here
some of these battles they're intense
and their puzzles - I mean RPG tradition
lightning spells work well against
robots and mechs things like that but
now that hits them and it weakens them
and so now you combo em until you
basically break them the like ah now I'm
stunned now you can really dig into them
so it has more action than I would think
of when I think Oh
Final Fantasy 7 Squaresoft RPG from the
90s but the action leads to filling up a
gauge filling up a meter unlocking
abilities and spells that you then use
and implementing your entire team to do
so so it doesn't lose the RPG element
you can call it an action RPG RPG is
still in the description I hope there's
a mechanic where let's say I'm
controlling cloud I'm getting low on
life and Barrett's the healer I hope I
can do like the final fantasy 12 gambit
thing where's like I have I'm low on
life just heal me maybe it's an option
maybe it's an option in here the demo
just didn't tell me about that I can do
maybe it's not an option at all you just
got a micromanager people I don't know
the boss the super scorpion death mech
the boss in this demo also the boss for
this part of the game also the boss in
the original Final Fantasy 7 demo at a
point heroes like I might die but you
can't die no I did it in my first
attempt but I was sweating I was
actually I was panicked and by the end
the place is falling apart doesn't keep
Jesse from hitting on cloud no might be
because of that cloud smirk when he
jumps over the pit
he gives them props that is a perfect
smirk not everyone can do that smirk I
can't yeah perfect smirk man-crush the
music - how are we're now gonna talk
about the music the soundtrack it's
hearing the familiar in Naboo omatsu
he's a legend he's the legend he's the
king he's the John Williams of musical
scores for video games and he's back to
work if you stick for this for the
remake and it is like when you're
listening to this you're like it's as if
Final Fantasy 7 became a movie but I was
impressed with it it kept the spirit of
Final Fantasy 7 made it cinematic and oh
by the way you get to play it it's a
game there's a great demo if you have a
ps4 pick it up play it I'm gonna play
through it quite a few more times so I
get the mechanics down you know get the
combat down get the combos down optimize
my attack 2 meter build the magic ratio
ups when the game comes out I am ready a
boss scared me the story of Final
Fantasy 7 is fantastic especially after
just replaying it tell me that story
bring it
my body's ready alright so the demo -
Final Fantasy 7 the remake have you
played it why did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more and by
the end the place is falling apart
doesn't keep Jesse from hitting on cloud
no still clouds not gonna smash Jesse
though Reno well
thanks for watching